اوكرانيين لم لم يكن لدينا اي شك في
اوكرانيا منذ بدايه الحرب رغم
التفاؤل الحروف الاوروبي وكذلك من كثير
لم يقدموا لنا فرصه من مئه بالمئه يعني
اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان نحن في الحال افضل المقارنه بما
كان عليه منذ 11 شهرا او منذ
عشره جيش الروسي لم تعود بهذه القوه كما
كان عند الهجوم لان لذلك الوقت روسيا
استعملت افضل كتائبها
مجاهده
اوكرانيا وكثير منها قد تم تدميرها والان
بعد التعبئه طبعا العدد الجنود الروسي
اصدادا ولكن
هذا الجيش
هو يتجدد او تصنع
بسرعه بطيئه مقارنه باستهلاكها داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لانه نحن الخطه الجاري
ونحن
كذلك على الوصول للاسحر المتطوره الى
اوكرانيا والارض
اقنعنا العالم بان يجب الصمود ويجب اثبات
فعاليه نطاق الامم المتحده وعدم تنازل على
اي شيء
لانه هذا سيحوس اخرين في العالم عالم
الذين يعتبروا قضيه يعتبرون ان لديهم
القوه اكبر مقارنه في جيرانهم او قد يكون
لديهم
الاسلحه النوويه ويجب للعالم عدم التسامح
في خلق القانون الدولي
لذلك اوكرانيا تصير على اخراج
القوات الروسيه بشكل كامل من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وهو بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
الانتصار موضوع اخر بشان دفع
الروسيه جرائد
وكذلك محاكمه المجرمين الارض
وتحمل المسؤوليه على الافاضه الجماعيه وكل
جرائم ارتكبتها روسيا في اوكرانيا والجهود
الروسي ونحن نعتقد ان يمكن ان نضغط على
روسيا عن طريق
حتى بعض خروج وحتى اعاده حدود
ثقه في حدود مطار دوليا 91
بواسطه الضغط اقتصادي حتى روسيا توافق على
التعويضات غير شيء
هذا سيكون اثباتا لميث
حرب العالميه الثانيه او او حرب العالميه
الثالثه
العضوان الروسي في البلدان الاخرى هذا
التاريخ من الادوان في اوروبا سينتهي
تسارع
استاذ ايفان اعتذر لانه علي ان اتوقف عن
طرح الاسئله بسبب رداءه الصوت من المصدر
يعني ساكتفي فقط بهذا القدر اشكرك على كل
حال على هذه المداخله